mesdames et messieurs les députés
insoumis vous m'avez insulté 15 jours
vous sortez mais vous m'avez insulté
personne n'a craqué comme presque tous
les Français on est assez concerné parce
qu'on a vu il y a pas eu vraiment de
débat il y a pas eu d'argumentation il y
a eu beaucoup de confusions on a été le
groupe le plus présent au niveau des
votes après oui on nous a un peu moins
entendu mais pourquoi et parce que c'est
la lupestre qui a totalement bloqué les
débats nous notre position depuis le
début c'est cette réforme elle est
douloureuse mais elle est indispensable
pourquoi nous n'avons pas déposé plus
d'amendements
vous souhaitez pas être là pour faire du
bruit on n'est pas dans une télé-réalité
on n'est pas là pour faire du bruit pour
du bruit à un moment ça n'a aucun sens
la nups a déposé énormément
d'amendements ça a apporté quoi ça nous
a empêché d'arriver au vote le cœur de
la réforme c'était 64 ans et le fait
qu'il y ait pas eu de débat pas un seul
débat sur cette question et pas de vote
pose un problème il dit incompréhensible
retrait des amendements du PCF
pourquoi se précipiter l'article de 7
hâte de se faire battre ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire on sait qu'on est
minoritaire on sait qu'on n'a pas de
majorité pour mettre en échec le
gouvernement et donc il faut faire
traîner les débats c'est ça que vous
dites c'est l'aveu de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais est-ce que c'est un allié du
mouvement social Jean-Luc Mélenchon
quand il fait des choses comme ça non
est-ce que vous contre le mouvement
social quand il fait ce genre de chose
il ne favorise pas la clarté des débats
chacun aurait pu aller voir tirer la
manche de son député en sachant
qu'est-ce que vous avez voté monsieur le
député vous avez voté pour contre
formidable gâchis puisque aucun des
acteurs n'en sort
victorieux ni le gouvernement ni
l'opposition et surtout pas les Français
les quatre composantes de la nupesse
vous ne vous parlez que par tweet
interposé vous ne vous parlez que par
communiqué de presse Inter
dites-nous quand vous allez divorcer il
est dans une stratégie lui il est dans
une stratégie qui est celle de ne pas
faire voter le texte pour que le
mouvement social puisse durer je
conteste cette stratégie mais il en a au
moins une
quel tri pèse or notes zattis not the
question comme je dis Afrique
c'est-à-dire parce que c'est pas le
sujet le sujet il y a pas à remettre en
cause c'est pas le sujet il promet de la
fermeté face au fléau de la conduite
sous stupéfiants le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin se dit
favorable au durcissement des sanctions
on arrête les retraites point pour les
petits excès de vitesse moins de 5 km à
l'heure en revanche on prive de permis
de conduire ce qui conduit ce stupéfiant
et sous alcool Gérald Darmanin
fait tout de suite une proposition sous
le coup de l'émotion de ce drame atroce
pendant le dossier Pierre Palmade une
enquête préliminaire et désormais
ouverte pour détention d'images à
caractère pénaux la pornographie
Emmanuel Macron affirme vouloir la
défaite de la Russie mais s'oppose à
ceux qui chercheraient à écraser Moscou
certains pays du Nord notamment veulent
faire la guerre à la Russie il y a des
débats au sein des pays de l'Union
européenne certains veulent faire la
guerre à la Russie aller jusqu'à Moscou
donc vu la position
nous devons faire respecter le droit
international conclusion c'est que la
guerre va durer elle va durer longtemps
elle va durer tant que il n'y a pas eu
un rapport de force militaire qui aura
été créé dans un sens ou dans un autre
les États-Unis ont formellement
déterminé que la Russie a commis des
crimes contre l'humanité et je dirais à
tous ceux qui ont perpétré ses crimes et
à leur supérieur complices vous serez
tenu pour responsable popularité
d'Emmanuel Macron en baisse c'est la
diminué de deux points en février
organisateur du premier championnat de
France de sabre laser présente
l'événement organisé au Palais des
Sports de Metz il s'agit bien d'une
compétition sérieuse sous l'égide
d'ailleurs de la Fédération Française
d'Escrime merci beaucoup merci à vous